morgen kommt eine runde als eine wette
machen wenn die wette machen
ok wollen wir eine wette bei wetten dass
ich morgen eine runde hochreiter wo ich
alleine schwalbe games gewinne
okay okay und das was bringst du für ein
einsatz was immer ekliges essen das er
heftig okay okay wir hatten so fest wenn
ich nicht schon morgen oder und o2 in
der ich alleine games gewinne dann esse
ich eine dose
so leute herzlich willkommen zum 10.000
versuch heute eine gescheite runde
aufzunehmen ich komme seit zwei stunden
sind wir hier
aber was macht man nicht alles für seine
abonnenten bei mir ist jetzt der
krankhafter und user sind da hallo hallo
ganz aus gemäßigte games hat ihr biotop
drauf machen auch witze montag wolle und
der eine und der andere
irgendwann hab ich gesagt krankhafter
ich meine natürlich peter hd
der täter hatte alles ja ich stehe
draußen
jetzt kriegt alles durch die ganzen
spawn kills der dult muss in den letzten
zweieinhalb ich muss ich muss ich muss
ich muss rein als kommt kaum zu meiner
route wasser würde ist da kann ich den
abfall gut ausgerüstet
da wo die op kiste ist die eine ach so
wenn wir den abfang endlich soweit ganz
gut ausgerüstet ja ich komme hier gerade
kommst du dir sippel alte politiker
porter wagnis schon wieder lachte ich
jemanden los und trotzdem seine route
ich habe den jungs gesehen dass ich mich
selbst zusammengelegt also ich lebe auch
noch kannst du schreiben wo wir sind
weißt du design objekt ist die 1
diese einst einzige im ganzen vorjahr
weil ich nicht trennen also ich renne
weg damit mich keiner sie so ninja
rechtmäßig am rand hier bei dem start um
den da bin ich gerade bist du okay ich
bin der der hier oben bei der kiste
steht
vier stücke ein die ich habe auch die
leute in der stadt werden wir alles
geben das zeugs apple das zeug habe ich
mich erschreckt alter der täter hatte
das bist du ja ich meine natürlich peter
hdds alter ich würde niemals mit
krankhafter auf dem peter hd mit der
saison halt einfach ist nur was unschwer
kommen hier entlang meine route weiter
ich brauche nikes
mclaren hat können wir uns auch ein
aber leider nicht der pds ist so krank
dass dieser name peter hd nennt man so
was machen würden
habt ihr alle sechs gold gold gold
das geht schon und ja leute wie gesagt
ich bin so frustriert ich versucht mit
halb links hier hier hier geht meine
route land gerade darauf laufen ich trau
dich drauf läuft passiert gar nichts
aber normalerweise nicht aus also wie
gesagt das ist eine wand gründe das
heißt ihr seht den ersten versuch
immerhin muss es ja keine als ist er
wirklich ist relativ spät und wir und
ich versuche zwei stunden was geschätzte
aufzunehmen und er ist also zahlen
geschaltet dass user sp vp wo ist dann
hat er dann hatten wir einmal nach zwei
minuten in der unteren stockwerk in
petting feier hat catching fire hoch und
so mäßig gelegt da ist ein name
wir müssen es apple zum zum job machen
die besten haben dass der gegner zwei
gegner geschmiert
geben sie euch oder nicht
ich probiere das absaufen links herum
ja ich komme jetzt erst richtig zum
alter ohne witz läuft auch junge ja ich
schon den boden halt dein maul die
trends in den anderen
scheiße aspekte und theologe jolo
das ist scheiße ich bin ich denn junge
war es andersrum rennen macht wie gesagt
jolo und ihr wisst bescheid da wird
jeder rennt immer die gleiche scheiße du
folgst sehen wo das noch mal voll dreh
durch auch einfach noch in richtung oder
bist du okay jetzt erstmal den peter
hier beste runde bis 10 uhr schweizer
zeit gegeben glaubt aber die anderen
sind auch noch hand ich bin jetzt über
zwei dumme ist das ähnlich unglücklich
box weiß man angst kaputt denn da kommt
eine freundin von rechts ist ich habe
zwei hat er beklaut hinterhältig in
deutschland hat nur zu hoffen ist auch
das ist es schon spät
also leute wie gesagt ich habe heute
zwei hat schon probiert etwas
hinzubekommen und es war wirklich
schwierig ist ein schlechter tag ist
wegen dieser runde jetzt irgendwie
gezwungen die hochzunehmen hochzuladen
das ist scheinbar die judo regeln
und ich würde aber zeitlich fällt auch
kein diese uhren söhne mehr durch die
runde fertig ist sondern heute einfach
mal rein
was meint ihr ist das okay
ja das problem
naja ich befehle
das war die feststellung verhalten in
dieser runde hat er sagen also leute
dann haut rein
die stars ananas morgen werde ich auf
jeden fall was raus land wo ich mein
bericht ich spiele weil ich da muss man
gewinnen oder sich abrunden und dies und
das sind uns ein bisschen anstrengend
deswegen morgen kommt eine runde weiter
kommen die wette machen und meine wette
machen wollen wir den battle weil wir
wetten dass ich morgen eine runde hoch
werde wo ich alleine survival games
gewinne
okay okay und deutschland was bringst du
für ein einsatz
sagen wir richtig widerlich der
hundefutter zwiebel nicht abartig soo 7
ich finde die an sich eklig ist so fest
wenn ich nicht schon von morgen und
wartet der ich alleine zweifel games
gewähr
dann esse ich eine dose in diesem sinne
drei leute